one
from Matt here
uh asking this can you discuss the
history of graph Theory and network
Theory what was the role of computation
so you know the idea of a graph is a
pretty natural idea but I don't think it
occurred until the 1700s uh as a sort of
a formal thing and it's usually
attributed to London Euler who um kind
of captured a past time of the time in
the city of konigsberg where he lived
which I think is now in Poland
um
there was an assembly of bridges that
went to an island to the mainland across
River et cetera et cetera et cetera and
the question was on the Sunday afternoon
stroll could you uh go
um over could you uh wander around these
Bridges
um uh going across every bridge uh just
once
um and uh
Euler figured out the answer to that and
figured out the answer I think was no
um and that was kind of and that's
what's led to what are now called
eulerian circuits of graphs
but that was kind of the first example
um I think that sort of uh in recorded
mathematical history of thinking about
the abstract graph just the connectivity
of where could you go on the bridges not
the geometry of where the bridges were
laid out
I think um
uh well let's see probably by the 1800s
um there were a bunch of other kind of
similar things I think um Hamilton
William Rowan Hamilton inventor of
quaternions
probably in the 1830s or so uh was
interested in analyzing this thing I
think he maybe even invented this thing
called the icosian game I I happened to
look at this recently it's a it's a
thing where you're you're interested in
you you lay out the the you kind of lay
out the net of an icosahedron and you're
interested in can you make a uh a path
that visits every uh node on that um uh
on that laid out net and I I guess that
that led to an alternative another sort
of examination of graphs and the
question of whether you could take a
graph and wander around it visiting
visiting the nodes rather than
um visiting the edges
and I think um
there's another sort of small appearance
of graphs and networks
so I wonder what other appearances there
were in the 1800s probably another case
will have been when people started
looking at chemistry and started having
the idea of chemical bonds although that
didn't really
get
uh I mean it was all rather vague until
probably the until quantum mechanics
came along in the 1920s and so on but
there was this kind of notion of oh
there's an atom and it's sort of
connected by a bond to this other atom
and so on and I think that led to a
collection of to thinking about graphs
that were these sort of abstract graphs
of collections of atoms and for example
I think these questions like how many
configurations of atoms can there be
there's Achilles theorem that says the
number of different possible Assemblies
of atoms that are entered in this graph
is something like end to the end or some
some such other number
um and that was again something will
have happened in the 1800s as a as a way
of thinking about abstract graphs
representing molecules of course people
didn't know that molecules were real
things at that time but people still
were imagining uh sort of uh
atoms linked by edges so to speak to
other atoms that was another kind of use
of uh
of
of graphs and I'm trying to remember
when the Benzene molecule
um when that was figured out
um and I'm thinking very early 1900s
maybe another case where sort of there
was a graph representing the molecule in
that case a hexagonal ring
but you know I have to say even when I
started doing science in the 1970s graph
theory was at best an obscure kind of
thing it was not a mainstream story at
all uh it was something where
uh you know turning things into a graph
was
um
um a
uh a thing that was sort of a a layer of
abstraction a layer of kind of oh
there's this field of graph Theory it's
sort of an area of mathematics maybe or
maybe it's an area of Applied
Mathematics
um but it's not something that was part
of the of the mainstream story of things
now I think there were other types of
graphs that have been invented
so for example in the probably 1920s
uh there was this big enthusiasm for you
know factories existed and people wanted
to make factories more efficient and
there was this kind of idea of of time
and motion study of people going to a
factory and saying you know on the
production line which thing has to be
put there first which then comes second
there was a husband and wife team
um
oh the gilbreaths I forget the Lillian
Gilbreth was the was the wife's name
um
they were sort of big on the time in
motion study uh business and
um they were among other things invented
flowcharts which were an example of a
kind of a graphical way to indicate kind
of the um uh the the sort of the the the
flow of actions and the dependencies of
one action on another kind of the causal
dependencies of things uh notably that
that um couple were were famous for
being very concerned with efficiency
um which led them to have uh
um some number 12 or something children
which led to the the book by one of
their children called Cheaper by the
Dozen
um it was kind of a uh
um
a kind of a a um a practical uh use of
sort of their efficiency studies but
that so that was another case
then for example there were Feynman
diagrams
that dick Feynman introduced in the
1940s I guess late 1940s uh a
representation of the progression of
interactions between Elementary
particles you know you have a a line
representing a sort of the space-time uh
line of an electron
um and that would be uh emitter Photon
which could be absorbed by another
electron and so on you would have a
graph representing that collection of
interactions I mean I have to say that
even in earlier times when relativity
had been being invented I don't know
whether Einstein was the one who started
off talking about world lines but um uh
this this notion of sort of there's a
line in space-time that represents the
uh the progression of a thing both its
motion in space and its progression
through time and then when you start
thinking about photons being exchanged
between things light pulses being
exchanged between things you're sort of
building up a graph there
um I'm not sure that that really arose
at something where people thought a lot
about graphs in modern times in our
physics project for example uh down at
the lowest level of things there are
giant causal graphs that represent all
of these Elementary events and their
inter and their relations with each
other and I suppose very Junior versions
of those
um I may have I'm trying to remember
whether I don't think that was in um
Einstein's uh sort of uh for example
popular books in the 1920s about
relativity and and things like that so I
think Feynman diagrams were sort of a
these sort of space-time diagrams a very
abstract interactions between Elementary
particles you could think of these
finding diagrams in some sense as just
being diagrammatic representations of
mathematical formulas but that was
another use of diagrams and again one
that felt a bit exotic
um so
the kind of the sort of the serious use
of graphs for sort of production
purposes and big graphs and things like
this I think that was a phenomenon of
the 1970s and 1980s I mean there have
been things that were for example
shortest path algorithms
um I think dijkstra's algorithm maybe is
from the 1960s
um of a way to given a graph
um given two points on the graph find
the shortest path between those now
clearly by the time people were
interested in doing for example uh
taking uh having maps of cities and Road
networks and things and finding what was
the shortest path from uh from one place
to another on roads you had to start
thinking in terms of graphs but I
certainly remember when I was a
consultant at thinking machines
corporation which was a parallel
Computing company in the early 1980s
um the uh there was interest in using
this parallel computer to do pathfinding
and graphs and things like this but that
was
sort of an exotic abstract kind of thing
to do one use case at that time was a
very early Direction assistance system
maybe I've told this story before but
it's a fun story so I can I'll tell it
anyway
um this was at a time before there were
cell phones before there was GPS and so
on and the question
was could you take a map and I don't
know how they had an electronic version
of the map
um but somehow they had an electronic
version of a map of Boston and uh that
had kind of the network connectivity of
the roads in Boston in it and so using
that network connectivity you could in
principle work out directions from from
here to there so to speak
um on this map
uh the question was if you were actually
going to use those directions and you
were kind of driving around how would it
know where you were and how would it
tell you those directions and so the
scheme used was there were pay phones in
those days and pay phones had numbers
and it was possible to get apparently
for Boston a uh something which gave
information on this pay phone with this
number is at this location
well I being an out of Towner at that
time at least
um uh said I'll volunteer to test this
uh Direction assistance system and I'll
you know start driving around Boston and
see if I can uh can use it and give
comments on it it was a total disaster
now you know I I should have had a
backup uh paper map to use I didn't
um and so there I was driving around
um and stopping a pay phone calling this
automated
um uh this voice response system
um and uh
uh trying to get it to tell me you know
which roads to go on next and the whole
thing was very I would say the user
experience was exceptionally poor I mean
it probably didn't help that uh you know
I hadn't really thought through oh I've
got to take notes from what I hear about
you know turn left turn right
Etc et cetera et cetera and there wasn't
a good way to get that list of oh it's
you know uh such and such street how do
I have to write that down in my notes
things like this but I got absolutely
irreducibly lost and it took um I don't
know probably four or five hours for me
to get back to uh where I needed to go
um from my experience in this direction
assistance system
um but probably the very first of its
kind and probably this must have been
1984 1985 uh type time frame but anyway
that gives some sense of the fact that
graph theory was just not really a a
well explored thing I think it really
became popular
um
coming into the 1980s and by the 1990s
it was it was uh very uh well-known I
mean when when by the time Mathematica
came out in 1988
um there was uh it was certainly a Thing
One new was of Interest although it
wasn't something that was so core that
in the very first version of Mathematica
it was a a thing that was a built-in
feature the combinator attack
combinatorica package by Steve Skinner
notably that name
um really emphasized combinatorics
rather than specifically graph Theory
although in fact there was a lot of
graph Theory and what was done there
you know there have been a few specific
things where sort of graph Theory had
kind of showed up like the Four Color
problem
um the question of whether given a a map
of the world let's say with countries on
it is there a way to color the countries
so that no two color no two countries of
the same color are next to each other
how many colors of countries do you need
to color the map that way and the claim
was that on a flat Earth
um uh you needed or even a spherical
Earth but not a donut-shaped earth you
needed um four colors
um to uh to be able to to always
successfully not have two neighboring
countries have the same color and that
theorem was proved actually it was a
computer proof by
um Appel and harken in
the 1970s maybe 78 or something and that
for color problem quickly turns into a a
graph problem because you think about
what country is adjacent to what other
country and you make a graph of the
adjacencies of those countries
um but I don't think people thought
about it particularly as a graph Theory
problem until after the fact so to speak
so uh yes I think that that graph Theory
really came into its own probably in the
in the 1990s probably
um and uh uh became something where
people were sort of abstracting from all
kinds of things as graphs it certainly
helped by the time the web came into
existence and everybody was thinking
about
um uh hyperlinks and so on that became
sort of an intuitive
version of a graph clearly graphs have
been used in other places I mentioned
flow charts another uh sort of use case
for graphs was the sort of The Logical
layout of things like I don't know the
London Underground train system for
example uh the maps of that were not
sort of geometrical geographical Maps
they were sort of connectivity maps and
so on and I suppose also another use
case
um will have an electric circuits where
one was just drawing the connectivity of
things not
um specifying where things were and I
guess that was yes that would have been
another thing uh the theorems that let
you like the star Delta transformation
that lets you say this collection of
resistors has in This shape has is
equivalent in resistance to this
collection of resistors I think those
theorems ah gosh when were those from
I'm kind of thinking the 1930s but I'm
not sure
um but you can tell from my rather
rambling description here graph theory
was was not really a very coherent uh
subject until quite late on and I would
say that um sort of it was
the existence of computers and the
possibility of studying graphs with
computers that really made it much more
feasible to deal with graphs I will
mention another thing about graphs
um the question of laying out graphs
that was really hard to do and for
example yeah I I used graphs a whole
bunch in the in the 1980s and the
mid-1980s to study a finite State
machines so so Finance State machines
had been represented by graphs since
they were introduced in the 19 uh well
1940s 1950s
um but they were not usually very big
graphs
um what in in the 1980s when I started
using finite State machines to represent
these sort of discrete dynamical systems
and cellular automata and things like
this uh those ended up being big kind of
computer generated graphs and I had a
very difficult time laying out those
graphs I was just recently found
actually a bunch of the the pieces of
paper where I had tried to lay out you
know 100 node graph and figure out where
to put the nodes so that you didn't have
a lot of lines crossing over I had
various efforts with pieces of string
and things like this but in the end I
think I mostly did it by just sort of
drawing it out and then redrawing it and
and so on it was a very tricky thing to
do automated graph layout was not
something that became seriously easy to
do until the 2000s
um at that time uh and it was an
important thing in our uh sort of
standardizing graph theory important
language which happened maybe 20 years
ago now
um it was uh
an important point was you make a graph
how does it actually appear
you know you want something where a
human can readily tell sort of what's
going on in the graph and for that you
need automatic fairly rapid graph layout
and the sort of most standard method
that became sort of uh was this kind of
a spring electrical kind of setup where
you imagine that there are nodes of the
graph and they are being pulled together
by Springs but they're repelling
electrically so to speak and that's kind
of the way you lay the graph out
but so so I think it probably will be
fair to say that the the existence of
computers and the fact that graphs could
be represented in computers uh in the
1990s probably was the thing that really
made a kind of graph Theory uh take off
and
um I think uh the the kind of
statistical study of graphs also kind of
originated around that time people
studying uh all sorts of um uh all sorts
of networks and asking statistical
properties of those networks that was a
thing of that time and clearly by the
time there was uh
by the time the web was getting
established also in the 1990s there were
started to be questions about sort of
visiting places on the web the kind of
the you know the pagerank algorithm for
deciding what's an important uh uh
what's an important website based on
sort of random walking around the graph
um uh in in um in that way you know I'm
I'm thinking as I'm trying to explain
this to you I'm thinking of all these
different very fragmentary places where
graphs had showed up always a little bit
exotic there was a thing called the beta
lattice Hans Beta had invented that it's
a tree like lattice
um where instead of um and and that was
a thing which had been introduced and
was was relevant for lots of sort of uh
easy to prove theorems and statistical
mechanics I'm kind of thinking that came
from the 1940s or 1950s
um so just an incredible number of kind
of fragmentary appearances of graphs and
networks that really became kind of a
coherent field I think pretty much in
the 1990s
let's see
uh
notorious commenting so graph Theory
evolved is a theory after practice like
thermodynamics and steam engine
there was theoretical graph Theory but
it was a very minority field
I mean I think that
um things like the Spectra of graphs
taking the adjacency Matrix and finding
its determinant I think that might have
been sort of known in principle in the
late 1800s but it was a really obscure
thing in the I mean I remember I made
use of Spectra of graphs in the early
1980s and it was like yeah you could
find a book on it but it was not a
mainstream kind of thing
um
and uh
that um uh yeah actually Peter here is
commenting Graf's knowledge
representation were popular in AI in the
late 1960s
um and more formally in theoretical
computer science a decade later yes
that's right that's another that's
another use was um people uh uh trying
to
represent
um
well let's see I mean the uh
this kind of
the the idea of a Knowledge Graph so to
speak I'm trying to think about
oh yeah I'm going to make another
another example another fragmentary
appearance this one I know the date 1912
was when game graphs first appeared they
were introduced by Unser Melo who was
most famous for his role in um in set
theory
um had the people have been studying you
know what were possible chess endings
and things like this
and he said with a lot of kind of
reference to set theory oh there's a
graph you could make that represents all
the possible states of the game
and I think uh you know when people
started talking about automated theorem
proving
which happened very early in the history
of computers
um I think there was some awareness that
that was kind of a graph related thing
although I don't think people had drawn
I mean even when I was first using
automated theorem approvers in the late
1990s people were not drawing the graphs
that got made by those things it was
still very much of a sort of an
algebraic thing behind the scenes
um I think people
um
yeah I think even with relational
databases other kinds of things yes I
certainly I certainly saw graphs being
drawn
um
in
to represent kind of the data structures
the the connections of pieces of
knowledge and things like that in fact
the very name I mentioned the connection
machine its very name came from the idea
that there was sort of a representation
of knowledge in terms of connections
between things as a graph I had
forgotten that I don't think the
connection machine really uh sort of the
graph aspect of all these connections
was something that came to the fore very
much once the machine had been built as
sort of this massively parallel machine
but yes that's a that's a good point and
I would say there are other examples
gushes is a fragmentary area it's
terrible
um another example is Petri Nets which
were kind of a representation of
originally of chemical reactions it was
kind of a a graph theoretic
representation of kind of what's going
on in a chemical reaction and what's
going on with multiple chemicals are are
involved I could say also in the 19th
60s there was starting to be metabolic
pathway charts that showed uh sort of
the the the collections of chemical
reactions that happen in a biological
cell for example again could be thought
of as examples of graphs but pulling
them out and saying this is a graph
let's analyze this as a graph I don't
think that happened until the 1980s I
think the idea that it was sort of
abstractly oh there's this chemical here
and it's connected to this chemical here
that existed certainly in the 1960s
possibly even a little earlier than that
but pulling it out as sort of a a data
structure on its own I think happened
later than that
um
so yeah messy history gosh
um you know I'm reminded of of these
things where for example you know
Euler's sort of introduction of that
idea based on this sort of you know
Pastime in the city of konigsberg
it's always fun when these things that
are sort of very kind of past time-ish
everyday kinds of questions end up
throwing up what ends up being deeper
mathematics so I just noticed recently
uh James Clerk Maxwell uh most famous
for electromagnetic theory for things in
statistical mechanics and so on
um he wrote in maybe the 1860s a paper
called on Hills and Dales
he had this uh estate in Scotland and
which he like walked around all the time
and so on and had these Hills and it had
these Dales of valley-like things and he
got curious about what amounts to the
graph of you know where can you have a
peak where can you have a valley how are
these all connected
later that whole question about you know
what maximum what Minima could exist and
so on got called Moss theory in the
probably 1940s or something but Maxwell
um had already sort of developed that
just on the basis of oh I'm curious as I
wander around you know just how many
times am I going to go up how many times
do I have to go down and so on
um the uh you know I'm I'm thinking of
yet more examples of graphs
um another one which I suppose was one
that I sort of mentioned a bit earlier
is Nets a polyhedra where you uh
um and things related to that where
you're asking you know what uh where you
have a lattice for example you know
asking what are the nearest neighbors
what's the connectivity of the neighbors
and so on those are things certainly
Nets of polyhedra were
pretty well studied by the late 1800s
and people were
um
the kind of
um I'm not sure if Kepler who studied
polyhedra a lot I'm not sure if he drew
Nets of polyhedra
um I think he was more thinking about
you know polyhedra in 3D so to speak
um
it's uh
let's see
um
you know I will say in terms of graphs
uh
you know I have become a huge user of
goths I myself
as I say used them sort of in the wild a
bunch in the 1980s as a way to represent
the kind of the states of these cellular
automaton systems that I was studying
State transition graphs I use them in
several different ways in cellular
automata
um actually this was probably early
1980s State transition graphs I was
generating large State transition graphs
um
I don't think that have been done much
with computers I'm trying to think about
that for shift register sequences people
were most concerned with maximal length
shift registers which have a very simple
State transition graph that's just a
great big circle with one zero State
separated from that
um but I myself became a huge user of
graphs starting well in the early 1990s
I got curious kind of what the
underlying structure of space-time might
be if there were discrete elements of
which space was made and I sort of knew
that it couldn't be some very regular
lattice like a cellular automaton it had
to be something much more flexible and
the thing that I started thinking about
was well it might be a graph later on I
realized it was better represented as a
hypograph that's very recent realization
um but back in starting in the early
1990s I kind have had this idea if space
is going to be discrete it must be a
giant graph and so I started needing to
be sort of a much more industrial user
of graphs and when I wrote my book A New
Kind of Science I had all sorts of code
in Wilson language for doing uh kind of
graph Theory sorts of things but those
was not a standardized part of language
until quite a few years later and uh
this question of of um was it difficult
someone asked to was it difficult to
integrate graphs into open language
um the answer is I would say that the
real sort of important uh technological
innovation was being able to do fast
automated layout of graphs because you
know to just represent a graph and say
blob here's a graph and you've got to go
look at its adjacency Matrix gotta look
at this properties but you can't really
see The graft is much less useful than
you make a graph and up it's right there
on the screen and you can actually
manipulate it by saying I've got a
function you know I say vertex count
Open Bracket and I put the graph right
in there that becomes a much better way
to do things now this whole question
about programming with graphs thinking
in terms of graphs it's an interesting
issue it's something people have tried
many visual programming languages where
one says let's represent things a bit
like having flow charts as the way of
representing the actual program
um it tends to work well when there's a
single chain of things you have to do do
this then this then this then this sure
you can represent that very easily by a
graph it's a rather trivial graph
sometimes when there's a single Branch
or two you can also represent it but by
the time you're doing more sophisticated
uh kinds of looping functional
programming things like that in my
experience it becomes very impractical I
mean it was something that um
was um
I'm trying to think in in the early
versions of logo the turtle motion
language invented by Simon puppet and so
on in the 1960s that was originally a
textual language where you'd say make
turtle go forwards this amount make it
turn make it go forwards and so on but
by the time it emerged into
uh mind storms that must have been in
the 80s and then scratch it had become
sort of a a visual sort of Click these
pieces together and see the flow type
type language and there were a variety
of other such languages a thing I've
often been interested in is whether
there is a way to truly represent sort
of
truly write code that is a graph
and what do I mean by that I I mean that
normally
sort of
programming languages and our
computational language are very much
based on sort of the metaphor of human
language which is essentially a
one-dimensional string of of tokens you
it's it might represent it might be
something where you have sort of a
hierarchical tree-like thing that you're
representing but in the end you're
writing it out as you know F of G of X
and so on all on a line in more from
language back in the in the mid 1990s we
kind of expanded that to sort of this
two-dimensional format for for math
notation where you could have sort of
built up pieces where you're not just
going all in one line but you can have
something where the actual language has
you know the an integral sign and it
knows that the limits are above and
below and just like in in a standard
programming language you might talk
about having a prefix operator like I
don't know a a um uh well I'll say a a
um like a not symbol an x-clamp or
something would be a prefix operator or
you might have a an infix operator like
a plus sign X Plus Y and so we have this
idea of overscript and um under script
operators things like that where where
instead of just going sort of linearly
you're you're taking the language being
in two Dimensions so I got interested in
the 1980s actually and whether you could
make a graph fix language a language in
which kind of the relations between
entities were sort of fundamentally
represented by something that was a
graph rather than something that was a
pure
um
kind of uh one-dimensional string or
even a one-dimensional string with some
sort of up and down pieces to it
I never managed to figure out how to
make that work at that time in fact I
concluded at that time that we humans
were not well built for thinking in
terms of kind of graph type
representations of things that we have
good built-in
um probably even hardware for dealing
with sort of what language which goes
sequentially and for dealing with things
in the world that it's sort of a
two-dimensional array of of things in an
image
but this notion of a graph was something
for which we don't have good sort of
intrinsic built-in Hardware or something
and so I I sort of thought that was not
such a good way to think about
programming even though it had many
interesting advantages
in more recent times I've sort of come
back to this question because when you
are thinking about well in our physics
project we're thinking about these giant
graphs that represent the causal
relationships between all events that
happen in the universe
and one of the things that goes on there
is this notion of multi-way systems
where you can have multiple threads of
History where different chains of events
are happening and one can think of some
of those events as being simultaneous
some of them as not being simultaneous
um and so on and there's this is
important moments thinking about
parallel Computing because that's
something where again one can have
different chains of events happening and
they're not happening in any sort of
that they can be multiple parallel
chains happening and so I've sort of
gotten re-interested in this question of
how can you make sort of programming
with in in the presence of these kind of
graphs of connections between things and
have a bunch of new ideas about how to
do that that are very much based on the
fact that we now have a pretty good idea
that physics works as sort of a thing
that emerges from all these underlying
graphs and so we can start using ideas
from physics like ideas like reference
frames and things to think about
um how to sort of make these graphs
comprehensible to us
um you know there's questions about
graphs it is interesting that
particularly with hypergraphs hypograph
is so a graph you're just taking uh the
nodes of the graph the the um the
vertices in the graph and you're saying
um every Edge connects to vertices
in and and in a hypergraph you can have
kind of triple hyper edges and things
like that where instead of connecting
two nodes together making a connection
between two nodes you make a sort of
simultaneous connection between three
nodes and so on
and hypographs have shown up in all
sorts of places
um they're still not very kind of
standardized we still haven't put them
as built-in things in woven language
because there are a bunch of different
ways you can think about hypographs and
it's not clear what the best one is and
whether it matters for example that the
hyper edges are are directed ordered
these kinds of things in our physics
project we think about those hyper edges
as just defining relations that's
something very similar to what happens
in things like relational databases
where you rep where you are dealing with
things in terms of hypographs and so on
or whether representations in terms of
that
um but uh
hypergraphs are still hypographs are
probably about at the stage today that
graphs were sometime in the 19 early
1980s let's say they're out there but
they're a little bit exotic
um and not yet sort of mainstreamed and
standardized
I think um
the but
hypergraphs are a very wonderful
flexible representation of lots of kinds
of things including I think the
space-time in our universe and things
like this but uh you can someone was
asking here about compiling things to
um
to graphs absolutely you can compile
things to hypographs and in fact in one
thing we've been looking at recently
about multi-computation the idea is
precisely to compile everything to
hypographs because hypergraphs have very
convenient properties in terms of uh the
sort of the causal relations between
events that update hypographs are very
cleanly representable it's very easy to
understand what's a change what affects
what and so on when you're dealing with
Hyper graphs so that's that's relevant
for those purposes
as a question here has anyone formulated
the Mellow Frenkel set theory in terms
of graph Theory
um
well okay so in my
fairly recent work on meta mathematics
it's a giant graph Theory story where
the nodes of the graph are theorems and
then you're asking for sort of the the
derivations of things are are
Connections in the in this graph and so
for example a proof
from one theorem derive another theorem
is a path through the graph
but in terms of the raw material
for set theory being graphs I don't know
of such a such a formulation although I
think it should be possible to make um
make such a thing
all right another question here from
Bennis at what point in history do
mathematics reach a level where a single
individual could no longer learn all
known mathematics within their lifetime
you know I have the impression let's
take some data points I think Euler
probably knew all the math
that was sort of going on at his in his
time and that was in the mid 1700s and
so on I think uh Gauss
in the early 1800s I don't know I I I
would think probably mostly
I would suspect that the time when
things
got to the point where there were
sufficiently many specialized areas that
you couldn't really you know get your
arms around all of math I think that
probably happened in the first few
Decades of the 20th century
um I think that um in
um you know I would even think people
like David Hilbert around the the end of
the 1800s had a pretty good global view
of what was going on in math and
certainly when Hilbert presented his his
23 problems at the
um International Congress and
mathematicians in 1900 that was sort of
an intended way of kind of sort of
touching all these different areas of
mathematics
so I would tend to think that um uh
sometime in the 1920s 1930s was when
that stopped being possible you know one
could sort of pick on particular people
and say you know did they know all of
math at their time you know whether it's
GH Hardy or whether it's John Von Neiman
these kinds of people
um my feeling is that by their time it
was not so easy
um and I think that there started to be
areas of math
I mean
math had been sort of a there have been
corners of math let's say number theory
that really hadn't developed much number
Theory had been almost a recreational
area with a few bits and pieces that
have been done with uh uh that were sort
of follow-ons from the Pythagorean from
Pythagorean triples and things like this
and diphantine equations
um but number Theory as sort of a a
major area didn't really come into its
own until probably the uh
maybe even the mid uh 20th century I
mean there have been uh sort of
contributions to it Riemann had made
connections between number Theory and
analytic kinds of an analysis calculus
and so on that was in the 1860s or 1870s
um and uh then well ramanujan in 1910s
um
was sort of introduced all these kind of
look at this amazing number theoretic
fact about you know this weird formula
for this this weird property of numbers
this weird thing about the you know the
number of partitions of an integer
things like this but at that time that
was still sort of a corner of
mathematics an almost recreational
corner of mathematics it didn't become
kind of really mainstream I would say uh
maybe until the 1950s or not even 1960s
um I I I noticed this once because I was
actually studying ramanujan and uh his
kind of uh practice of sort of doing
experimental mathematics which confused
people like JH Hardy who were very much
into let's make proofs of everything was
just like I'm gonna I'm gonna see
whether this relation looks like it
holds I'm going to try a bunch of
examples and I'm going to have good
enough intuition to know whether it's
likely to be sort of globally true but
uh I was surprised that his work hadn't
really gotten much attention around the
time it was done in the 1910s and so on
and it had taken quite a few decades
before it really really started to get
serious attention and that I think was a
result of the fact that number Theory
had not been a a widely thought about
area of mathematics and I think as these
different sort of errors and Mathematics
whether it's um uh started to sort of
come online I think that fragmented the
field to the point where it was no
longer possible to have this sort of
universal view of everything that's
going on
um now you know one can have a pretty
good sense of sort of the core
the core of mathematics
um you know many good mathematicians
have that
um but I think that there will always be
sort of at this point there are there
are enough sort of vertical towers of
mathematical development that um uh that
are quite separated from other ones
um
I would say that one of the things
that's sort of a trend in modern
mathematics
with things like the langlands program
for example is can you pull it all
together again you know a big Discovery
from Descartes in the 1600s was the fact
that geometry is representable
algebraically the fact that geometry and
algebra have a certain equivalence
between them and that was something that
really informed a lot of mathematics in
the in the particularly 1800s I would
say and uh and now there's this question
of is there a are there much bigger
correspondences between different areas
of mathematics that might in the end
allow one to have a much more kind of
universal picture of mathematics by by
learning only one thing you know it's a
it's a common feature of the development
of Science and other things that
there'll be sort of something that
develops and there'll be lots and lots
of cases that get studied and it might
take a really long time to get educated
about all those cases but then
eventually those cases all get sort of
rolled up together in some abstraction
and then you just learn that abstraction
you don't have to learn all the cases
and that keeps the sort of Frontier of
Education finite if it wasn't for that
it would be truly hopeless because there
will be sort of all this different
knowledge that's been accumulated and uh
you know if it wasn't getting abstracted
into bigger buckets so to speak it would
be very hard to learn that and it's the
same type of thing with mathematics I
think there's a certain effort in modern
times to see whether one could sort of
pull together a lot of these different
areas in these kind of Mega theories I
have to say I think that our my analysis
of kind of
um the physicalization of matter
mathematics tends to suggest that that
must work and it sort of must work
because there's a certain sort of
uniformity in meta mathematical space
different places in mathematical space
correspond to different kinds of fields
of mathematics but just like space and
physical in the physical universe is
quite homogeneous things are pretty much
the same in terms of for example laws of
physics at this place in the universe
and at some other place in the universe
I kind of think that the same is to a
mathematical space and then in the end
there are correspondences there must be
correspondences between these different
mathematical areas and there's a certain
sense in which things like category
Theory capture some of those
correspondences
um but that in the end it must be
possible to kind of talk about
mathematics in a much more unified way
you know category theory is a modern
last probably 20 years or so effort to
have a formulation of a bunch of areas
of mathematics that um has that sort of
commonality between different areas I
tend to think that category theory has
certain specific sort of make it
tractable assumptions which will sort of
lock it out of some kinds of discussions
of mathematics but in the places where
it works it begins to give you this kind
of universal view of what's going on
memes is commenting here it seems uh
too often Amazing Discoveries go years
without being picked up by a particular
Community yeah absolutely I mean the
there are uh you know it's complicated
how
you know in order for a discovery to get
picked up there has to be sort of a
conceptual framework and to some extent
a kind of social framework
that that Discovery can fit into
so you know there are things that people
notice things I've discovered in my my
time for example where I realized there
were sort of precursors of those things
from 100 200 years earlier but there was
no framework into which to fit those
things yes the digits of pi look kind of
random but so what
well eventually you get this whole
framework where you think about the
generation of complexity by
computational processors and then that
starts to fit in and uh and be something
that's interesting but
earlier than that it was just sort of a
random fact that didn't seem to fit in
anywhere you need these kind of
Frameworks to kind of support having
sort of things that were as a point
thing discovered much earlier
you know I have to say it's it's some uh
there are there are different dynamics
of of sort of things that got discovered
and then uh didn't really get picked up
I mean neural Nets are a great example
invented in 1943 or so but finally sort
of really really picked up in the last
decade or so
um that was a an unusual case because I
think that was a case where sort of the
conceptual framework kind of existed but
one needed practical technology tools to
really make
something out of this idea
it's sort of unusual because most the
most common situation tends to be you
don't even know that it's a thing until
you have some of the tools necessary to
study it and by the time you have those
tools you can build a framework and you
can start to to ex sort of integrate
things but yeah there are there are lots
of examples of where things were sort of
discovered ahead of their time often as
isolated facts and not really picked up
now it's confusing when one studies the
history of science because there's a
certain tendency once one understands
something in today's terms in the
framework that's been built up you go
back and look and you say wait a minute
those squiggles that somebody wrote down
a thousand years ago they remind me of
what I now know and what I Now
understand in this framework really this
was discovered a thousand years ago
because look at that squiggle and you'd
probably be wrong and probably you know
if you went back and talked to the
person who made that squiggle they and
said to them hey we've got this modern
thing and it works this way they'd look
blankly at you and they because they
wouldn't know that modern framework but
even if you go back and sort of probe
what they were thinking when they wrote
that squiggle it would be something
pretty far distant from what one has in
in sort of modern times I mean this
question of sort of communicating ideas
across history is a difficult one and
there are ideas that are rather
straightforward to communicate they are
very they're things where we've built a
tower where we go back and we look and
the tower we built really had the things
that were there let's say axioms from
Euclid or something as bricks in that
Tower and they're also places where one
looks back and the things one can see
are features of human nature where we
can understand them because human nature
back in ancient Greek times is no
different from Human Nature today so far
as we can we can tell and so that that's
another place where you can you know
have that kind of understanding but when
it comes to I don't know some thing
about computation where you might say
well there's sort of an ancient Greek
analog of this
um and uh you know let's try to go back
and explain that I mean like for example
I don't know
um the you know heraclitus was big on
the sort of everything is flow there is
nothing unless there is change so to
speak
I realized recently our modern theory of
how space Works physical space works
it's just like that there are all these
sort of uh we call them eems these atoms
of space and the the way in which there
are relations between those atoms of
space the way in which those relations
uh sort of come to exist is by virtue of
events that change these atoms of space
in ways that are correlated with other
atoms of space so in other words space
wouldn't be a thing it wouldn't be
knitted together as a thing where it not
for the sort of continual process of
change but I sort of Imagine going back
to old heraclitus and explaining to him
the kind of theory that we have now
about causal graphs and these slices of
scozographs that make hypographs that
limit to the structure of space and so
on and the question is you know his
statement everything is changed there is
nothing without change so to speak uh
you know could one really have made the
made the connection between these modern
ideas and what heraclitis was talking
about or is is that really sort of an
irreducible distance between those kinds
of sets of ideas I'm not sure I kind of
tend to think that there's a fairly
irreducible distance and that it isn't
that you know you're sort of you can
take the modern idea and you can back
project and say it's cool that there's
something that sort of was a shadow of
that idea that existed long ago but in
some sense it wasn't really the same
idea when you ask of a modern idea can
one build a tower on top of that idea
and if the answer is yes for that idea
but then you go back and say well could
heraclitis have built that tower on the
base of what he was talking about and
the answer is no then you have to kind
of think well it isn't really the same
idea in some sense
let's see
uh
questions here
um
oh actually the question here very
relevant to this release if Aristotle
were alive today how might he describe
modern technology how would one explain
modern technology to someone from
Aristotle's time
interesting question you know I I
thought about this I I thought um
a few decades ago actually I was
thinking of writing some kind of book
maybe I'll eventually get it done I've
sort of fictionalized interviews with uh
scientists and other thinkers of long
ago and I kind of had this um
kind of setup which was you're there
with your laptop
and you've got your laptop and you're
opening it and you're showing Pythagoras
how things work on your laptop and so
then I've sort of wondered well what
would Pythagoras think the laptop is
and you know I think one imagines that
let's see what it was doing and would
think it was some kind of form of
disembodied soul that existed in the
laptop and and you kind of wonder about
the conversation which goes like well
you know this these actions that are
happening in this laptop this sort of
spontaneous action that we can see on
its screen that's kind of like a
disembodied Soul doing things you might
say well well you know how did it get to
be able to do those things oh I might
say people programmed it to do those
things oh so I might say well is that
you know is it the case that they sort
of put you know that that act of
programming is kind of like transferring
sort of the disembodied Souls of the
laptop so to speak and one can imagine
you know I kind of think that's probably
in the in the Pythagorean period this
notion of sort of when you see this you
know computation is something a bit like
their notion of a soul a bit like a sort
of disembodied process that is not not
that is sort of can be physicalized but
can be physicalized in different ways
that that's the kind of way that that
would be that that would play I think
one thinks about more more modern times
that people like Newton for example I'm
kind of guessing that Newton would
imagine that it was some form of alchemy
that it was some sort of collection of
complicated chemical processes that were
happening that were causing the screen
to do all the things it was doing
um that that would be that would be the
picture there maybe
um but for Aristotle
um
I'm kind of thinking that uh the um
some of modern technology
will be sort of thought about in terms
of disembodied Souls that will be kind
of the computation idea
the notion that you can
well let's see I mean there are many
many pieces of Technology sort of had
precursors I mean something like
a
uh you know a camera and the ability to
take the image from the camera and put
it somewhere else I mean there were
pieces of glass and sort of the
beginnings of lenses although not really
image forming I think back in those days
so that wouldn't be so shocking
um I think when it comes to um oh I
don't know what's a piece of modern
technology I don't know an airplane for
example
um I
I kind of think that
um
you know I wonder to what extent
that would be a thing that will be
thought about in terms of its sort of
how would it be implemented by having
you know a flock of geese I mean Lucian
back in in the in Antiquity had already
described you a trip to the moon
um you know on a on a sleigh uh sort of
uh flown by geese if I remember
correctly
um
and uh
so you know seeing an airplane yeah I
mean the the thing that I suppose would
be notable is the fact that so many
things that were at that time purely
biological kinds of actions like being
able to fly things like that the fact
that they could turn into things that
could be done with machines
um is uh uh is surely notable although
it's not like there wasn't the idea that
there could be a machine coming from the
sky I mean that's what the the deus ex
machina of Greek plays was kind of the
you know the The elevator-like Descent
of uh some some some character into the
middle of the play so I think the the
idea had certainly Arisen that you could
you know have a thing that but but how
that how that kind of um uh you know how
that would be achieved technologically
that was that was not known I mean I'm
trying to wonder what would be some of
the things that would be the most
surprising I mean I don't think that
modern medicine for example the fact
that oh you take this you know this drug
and it it cures you of this or that
thing
you know there were plenty of Hubble uh
sort of medical ideas that existed at
that time and the fact that these things
were you know were packaged up and put
in these little pilled you know pill
containers I don't think would be that
notable
um I'm trying to think about other other
kinds of technology I mean I think that
uh you know a car for example an
internal combustion engine or an
electric car or whatever the um the fact
that
um
the fact that it's sort of possible to
have
um a thing that sort of spontaneously
can drive itself around uh surely is
notable
um although uh you know this question of
well it could be a little donkey inside
there that's that's um you know that's
that's turning those Wheels
um I'm not sure that the the lack of a
donkey
um in connection with the car you know
how that would be how that sort would
sort of be read but I yeah it is a very
interesting question what
um how one would describe things you
know I've sort of thought and somebody
should do this of training an image
identification system uh with only those
kinds of objects that you find in an
ancient Greek dictionary
um and so imagine that the world only
has the kinds of things that exist in
Antiquity and now you point the image
identifier at some Modern kinds of
things what would it say that telephone
is given that it only has in its kind of
visual lexicon the things that existed
in antiquity
um I think yeah I suppose that's another
yeah that's another big area is radio
and all those kinds of things now that's
that's a um
um
uh you know I don't know to what extent
uh
I mean in in
a lot of traditions this notion of kind
of the spirit world or something where
things happen but we can't see what's
going on it's pretty common not sure
that Aristotle was so bought into those
kinds of things but that's certainly
been a common tradition and so the fact
that you know there's radio and it's a
thing we can't we can't see but it
nevertheless communicates from here to
there might not have might not really
seem that notable
I mean it's uh
it's a question
you know at different times in history
this was particularly big I suppose in
the things like the 1940s and 1950s was
the kind of um whole uh extra sensory
perception and uh you know can you have
direct brain to brain communication
um through some mechanism uh that uh
might still might still exist who knows
um but we don't know it yet
um but uh the fact that things like that
might be possible
um I think was not inconceivable in
Antiquity
um it just the actuality of oh yeah you
can have a cell phone and you can be
talking to somebody else there that
obviously wasn't there but that that
would be inconceivable I think is
probably probably not not the case it's
an interesting question what the most
surprising pieces of modern technology
would actually be the most kind of I I
mean I I think computers would be high
on the list of um uh most surprising
kind of kind of Technology
um
yeah it's some
spare parts is commenting would you say
the word Soul or Spirit was used in the
pasta much the same way we use the term
software today
um in some ways I mean I think
computation is right kind of the the
abstract thing which is the abstract
process that goes on in things like
brains
um and that is somewhat similar to the
abstract thing that a soul was supposed
to represent when that was first being
talked about that there was something
about brains that had an
eternal character to it that was
abstract not a thing that was a property
of the physicality of a brain but
something that had some existence
independent of that physicality that
that was so I think yes I think that's a
a a a good correspondence between those
things and it's quite interesting to me
at least that so much thinking was done
about the character of Souls and so on
um in a time before sort of modern
science and many of the sort of logical
deductions that were made about things
like Souls probably applied today to
things like computation and it's it's
it's an interesting kind of circulation
of a we talked about sort of things that
showed up before their time the idea of
of the disembodied thought
is something that surely showed up long
before it could be embedded in the
framework that we have today for
computation
um I should probably wrap up soon here
let me just see
um
well uh
Roku says why would cell phones be
inconceivable they would work the same
way speech does the only difference is
that the Ancients didn't know about
leisurement field I think that
the concept that you could talk here and
somebody could you know hear you a long
way away it's a little weird it's not
incredibly weird it's a little weird
um
I again I I think
that
uh
it's an interesting question what
for example well our own efforts like
with Wolfram language and so on the
ability to compute things like
mathematical kinds of things how
surprising would that have been
to a Pythagoras or whoever else
um
you know again in the
more as discovered earlier than you
think the antichythera device the kind
of clockwork computer that we know we
have one example of from Antiquity
um
is a case where there was sort of a
mechanical mechanism for computing
something in that particular case uh
various astronomical phenomena but
the the idea that this laptop box or
whatever could compute you know
Pythagorean triples and just print them
out on the screen
um yeah we can even we even have a a you
know for compatibility with ancient
times we even have a Greek numeral form
that you can uh use where Pythagoras
would have been right at home in terms
of the way the numbers were represented
it's like okay here are a whole bunch of
Pythagorean triples you know roll them
out quickly
um would that have been notable I don't
know
um it's uh
as I said I think that the best model
that a Pythagoras would have had is this
kind of disembodied human soul type
model for what was going on in in in a
computer
um
Kelly is asking here my experience have
there been major changes to a field of
study that changed the way one would
view a certain topic
I remember being in school studying
astronomy when Pluto was declared to no
longer be a planet
and uh
the professor had to adapt their lesson
plan in the instant
um
yes there are absolutely things that
change how unuser topic I think for
example our physics project
in time will completely change the way
that one talks about space-time and
quantum mechanics and so on uh even the
things I've done recently on the second
world of thermodynamics
should be things that are used to
explain the second order of
thermodynamics from the beginning
um and uh
the it's interesting in in all three of
those cases actually that the way that
one explains these things today is much
more abstract
than what ends up being possible with
the kinds of things that have come out
of our physics project
it's um
something where in a sense
one has to
in that particular area one has to sort
of tiptoe around what's going on rather
than just saying here step by step is
what's going on
I've seen that actually a bunch of times
that
when the foundations of something get
better understood one can start just
talking in terms of those much more
solid foundations and it's actually
easier to understand what's going on
than when one is merely describing kind
of this thing floating in the clouds
very abstractly without sort of Bedrock
type foundations I think that's a pretty
common phenomenon that leads to sort of
a change in the way that things are
presented now they're also just straight
sort of new facts that are discovered
and you know when people were teaching
about oh I don't know genetics before
the discovery of DNA they will have
described it a little bit like what I
was just talking about they will have
described all these phenomena and all
these different details about oh we've
noticed that when you cross this with
that you get this thing and there's this
Rule and there's that rule and all these
kinds of things and then new Bedrock you
know we know genetic information is
stored in this molecule and it's stored
as digital information and then you have
kind of a completely different way of
explaining what's going on
I think that that um uh
that's that's another example of where
kind of the um
um
uh the the things that um uh how that
works now you know I'm always amused
because biology is a field that's
Advanced a lot over the last sort of
50-ish years
um since I kind of learned it in school
and uh
um I'm always amused every time I see
mention of the Golgi apparatus I
remember that when I was studying you
know cells when I was I don't know eight
years nine years old whatever it was you
know memorizing the different organelles
in the cell and memorizing the fact that
the gold reapparatus was an organelle of
unknown function
um and the endoplasmic reticulum
likewise and so I find it very amusing
that that's now you know you look in a
Modern Biology textbook and there's a
whole chapter about how those things
work and what they are and how they're
involved in protein synthesis and so on
and uh but for me back you know at that
time it was memorizing you know this is
an organelle of unknown function
so things like that happen
um and I think uh there are now in terms
of things that happen very suddenly
that's an interesting question what has
been discovered suddenly that led people
to change how they describe things
um possibly the Michelson Morley
experiment around 1900 uh discovering
that there wasn't an ether ether drift
that made one not want to describe there
being a luniferous ether but I think for
a while people don't really know what to
substitute for the Lima reference ether
and my guess is if you looked at the
textbook the interesting question to ask
how long did it take before mentions of
The luminiferous Ether died out in
textbooks my guess is a quite a long
time I mean my guess is that one will be
shocked how long sort of things survive
in textbooks uh after one really knows
much better ways to talk about them and
and a very common phenomenon is this
so
for example let's say there is a modern
Discovery in physics like some of the
things we've done
well people who are like teaching
physics might say to themselves wait a
minute first we teach classical physics
of Newton then we get to Modern physics
of uh you know Einstein relativity
quantum mechanics and then okay the very
Advanced thing that's very much you know
recent is oh this modern stuff about uh
discrete computational models of physics
and so on
um but that's very modern that's you
know the end of the chain of sort of the
historical progression of physics but
that's completely the wrong way to teach
it because in fact that sort of the
things we've done in recent times are
much easier to understand than for the
typical person
when you start from that then when you
say you sort of wave your hands around
and say oh well there's this equation
that you have to memorize that works
this way and nobody knows why it works
that way but you just have to memorize
it
the fact that when someone has a
fighting chance to understand the
Bedrock of of why things are built the
way they're built makes it much easier I
think for people to understand you know
I I found it notable when we built
Mathematica
um
and we have this notion of how functions
work and how you know f of x blank means
you'd have an f and then there's
anything blank and you name it X and you
transform it to something on the right
hand side
well that's a a very much more
mechanical view of what a function is
than what you think about typically in
pure mathematics and what I found really
interesting was that people who are
teaching calculus in the early days with
Mathematica back in 1988 and so on
um were telling me you know we always
used to have trouble explaining what a
function was abstractly mathematically
but now that we have Mathematica and it
has this concrete mechanical
representation of what does a function
do it takes a blob of stuff that sort of
you can put it in the slot and it
transforms it in this way it became a
lot easier to explain the notion of
functions in calculus because you were
not floating up in these abstract clouds
you were kind of doing things from kind
of mechanical Bedrock so to speak so I
think that's a a thing which again
people often get wrong in thinking about
teaching they think the newly discovered
knowledge must be taught lost because it
is the thing because there must have
been a progression of knowledge that led
to it and you have to build that Tower
to get to the modern thing but often if
the modern thing has really managed to
sort of reset and and solidify the
foundations of the field that may be the
thing to start from but that's something
that um is often got wrong as I said
um
memes is is commenting
I wonder what uh Professor Einstein
would have been able to do with wolf and
Alpha
you know I think when when Einstein came
to the institute for advanced study in
Princeton some he was uh in 1930s
three-ish I think
um it was already where it's very famous
and um sort of a celebrity scientist and
general celebrity
um and so he had uh you know a rare
scientist who had sort of the paparazzi
type um uh folks buzzing around him but
um
uh somebody asked him professor Einstein
what equipment will you have at the
institute for advanced study to help you
with your research and I think he
responded this might be an apocryphal
story I don't know I didn't really check
this but uh he apparently responded the
main thing I will have is a garbage can
to throw away the paper of all my wrong
theories and so on
you know Einstein
was a person of I would say very
uh penetrating sort of
philosophical style intuition about
physics
it was interesting to me to study
recently uh
his early work particularly in
thermodynamics and his efforts to do
things like derive the second order of
thermodynamics didn't work
1903 1904 was working on the second law
of Thermodynamics didn't work out
1905 he takes some of the same kind of
in a sense sort of philosophical
intuition that
he and other people had put into
thinking about the second law and he
applies it to sort of
the uh the idea of photons the the
discreetness of the electromagnetic
field the um uh the the kind of
mechanics and its relationship to
electron Dynamics and relativity and
Brownian motion all in 1905 and it just
works in all those cases and I think
that Einstein was
someone who had just very this very sort
of
sort of take it to the bare principles
kind of intuition about physics and so
on and I think he could see in many
cases there was a kind of mathematical
structure that those bear principles
revealed that happened with brown
emotion it happened to some extent the
relativity and things like four vectors
um it uh it later happened quantum
mechanics although he wasn't as involved
in that
um and it happened very in a very large
scale with general relativity in 1915
that you could kind of see there's a
mathematical structure here and there's
got to you know an okay mathematicians
do you have something that fits into the
Michael structure and in the case of
Relativity you know Hermann mikovsky
showed up and had knew about quadratic
forms and started talking about four
vectors and so on in the case of general
relativity
um I think uh besso was the person maybe
who introduced Einstein to tensor
calculus and the whole riemann's work on
differential geometry and things like
this and was and Einstein was fond of
saying that um uh you know he really
wasn't mathematically very sophisticated
and I think he was part of a long
tradition of physicists where you can
see you need the math
but you've got to kind of drag it in
from from what mathematicians have done
and then potentially reform it for
yourself and do computations with it and
I think the uh
I have no doubt
that um uh
this sort of ability to compute
would have been something that would
have been super useful to understand I'm
not sure that I I maybe Einstein was
more of a sort of think about the
principle of the thing more than a
Computing kind of person I mean people
like Gauss and Riemann were very
computer-oriented Computing oriented and
some of these people were more kind of
tech savvy than others like Gauss for
example was tech savvy enough to try and
hook up kind of an early Proto fax
machine based on a telegraph system for
his Observatory and you know he did
actual astronomical observations
discovered the asteroid series for
example
um but uh uh the um it was some uh it
was something so he was Gauss was very
tech savvy uh I think Hilbert was uh
amusingly somewhat Tech Sally
I know Hilbert people found it
entertaining that um uh you know the
esteemed Professor really liked his
gramophone his um uh oh gosh what is a
modern translation of gramophone uh
turntable audio thing for people who are
too young to know about these things
um vinyl records you know little needle
runs through the grooves and plays
sounds and so on that was high tech of
its time and actually I should have no I
I'm being unfair to Einstein perhaps
because Einstein uh you know when he got
his PhD uh you know he went to work at
the sort of the then analog of Silicon
Valley which was the the patent office
at Byrne where he was very much dealing
with inventions and particular
refrigerators and things like that which
were the um
you know refrigerators were probably the
the large language models of their time
so to speak
um but uh yeah that was some
uh
um
so yeah so I think I think Einstein
would have um
would he have used a computer did
Einstein use Einstein could have used a
mechanical calculator and I wonder if he
did I don't know
uh certainly Von Neiman did
um
I think
uh
I know that Gauss a lot of hand
calculation which is in published in his
papers he just calculated things on the
side like the number of primes and so on
in a particular interval things like
that
um it is an interesting question which
of those folk would have
really embraced using tools and how
quickly they would have done so I mean
my observation in Modern Times And I
should close with this my uh my
observation is from just looking at
people who use the tools that I've been
involved in building
um it is a a very nice stratum of the
kind of high end of the research
Community it is a really notable thing
that you know it'll turn out that
somebody who's a big user of our
technology and you know that's sort of
all I know about them and it will turn
out oh actually they're a leading person
in their field
and maybe the not so leading people
don't use that technology and uh you
know I can I can take I think it's
correlation not causation perhaps
um it is the case that people who end up
being able to make uh there's a certain
sort of uh
tendency to use kind of use tools and
use the best tools and learn tools and
things like that that tends to come with
the package of being really effective in
doing kind of the high end of research
in particular areas
um and I've just noticed that
correlation really quite dramatically
it's really quite um uh almost amusing
to me because I literally I'll know
people just because they happen to be
big users of our technology and will
really not happen to know anything about
the field that they that they work in
and then I'll discover well actually
they're a leading person in that field
and um it's sort of a remarkable
correlation
anyway I should wrap up there and uh I
think go back to my day job and I think
I have another live stream actually
coming up in just a couple of minutes
here but thank you for a bunch of
interesting questions and comments today
and uh look forward to seeing you
another time
bye for now